We've seen a reasonable
number of acid
reactions and base reactions.
So let's just write down a few
of them for review and let's
see if we can see a general
pattern here.
And a lot of this might not
be any news to you.
So if we have hydrogen flouride,
or if it's in an
aqueous solution it's
hydrofluoric acid.
We know that this is a weak
acid-- it doesn't disassociate
completely.
So it's in equilibrium.
Some type of equilibrium.
That doesn't mean the
concentrations are equal.
This hydrogen disassociates.
Actually, we know in reality,
it tags a ride along with
another water molecule
and forms hydronium.
And then you have-- and, of
course, this is still aqueous.
Everything is going
on inside water.
And then you have left over
your fluoride anion, or
negative ion.
And that's also in an
aqueous solution.
And we could have rewritten--
actually, let me write another
reaction here, just so you can
see the general pattern.
Let me write another
acidic reaction.
Let me write ammonium.
So that's NH4 plus-- it's
ammonia with an extra hydrogen
in an-- let me just write that--
in an aqueous solution.
That can disassociate to one of
those hydrogens popping off
in an aqueous solution.
And then you have
ammonia, NH3.
That's also in an aqueous
solution.
Now both of these describe an
equilibrium reaction, but it
kind of implies that we're
dealing with weak acids.
You take an acid, and they're
producing hydrogen, which is
at least the Arrhenius
definition of an acid if you
looked at the Bronsted-Lowry
definition where they're
donating protons to
the solution.
They're creating hyrdonium,
they're donating protons to
the water around it.
But it kind of describes
it as an acid.
But we know it's a weak acid,
so this reaction goes in two
directions.
So we can write the same
reaction essentially as a
basic reaction.
So we can-- instead of saying
hydrofluoric acid is our
acid-- we could say hey, if I
just have a fluoride anion, if
I just have a negative fluoride
here, I could say a
negative fluoride, if I put
that in-- actually, I keep
making that same mistake.
The fluorine does not
have an l in it.
I do that because
chloride does.
Let me erase this.
Hydrogen fluoride is HF.
So it's just F there.
Let me go to the
periodic table.
See, I always confused fluorine
with chlorine because
F is just for flourine.
But you get the point.
OK.
So I could rewrite the same
weak acid equilibrium as a
weak base equilibrium.
Or I could say a negative
fluorine anion in an aqueous
solution is in equilibrium
with-- and now we're saying
I'm considering this a base,
which means that it's going to
increase the concentration
of [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So what this might want to do is
it might want to grab some
hydrogen from some of
the water that's
in the aqueous solution.
So it grabs some hydrogen and
becomes hydrogen flouride, or
hydrofluoric acid.
Let me do that in that
magenta color.
It's aqueous.
And where did it get
this hydrogen from?
Well, it got it from one of
the surrounding water
molecules, which was H2O.
Since it gave away one
of the hydrogens now
it's just OH minus.
So the surrounding water
molecule is OH minus aqueous.
Now these might look
different.
This is donating a hydrogen to
the surrounding medium, and
then you're left with just
the fluorine molecule.
Well, this is essentially
creating a hydroxide molecule
out of the surrounding medium so
it looks basic, but if you
think about it, these reactions
are the same.
I mean, you could have just
gone in reverse direction.
You could say, hey, this is
going to react with some
random hydronium molecule or
some random, free-standing
proton out there.
And then it could form hydrogen
fluoride, but we know
that hydronium isn't just
sitting everywhere, that
whenever you take the reverse
reaction, whenever you're
going in this direction this
doesn't have to grab this
hydrogen from an H3O.
It could grab it from an H2O.
And then you would have
this reaction.
These are equivalent.
And we could do the same thing
here for ammonium and amonia.
We could write ammonia
as a base.
NH3 is in equilibrium as a weak
base with-- it can grab a
hydrogen from its surrounding
medium and become NH4 plus in
an aqueous solution.
And then it would have grabbed
that hydrogen, probably from a
water molecule because that's
what's around it.
And so that water molecule
will become an OH minus.
And so now this looks ammonia
is a weak base.
Ammonium is a weak acid.
But these are equivalent
reactions.
Now, you're probably already
seeing a relationship here.
Ammonium is a weak acid.
Ammonia is a weak base.
And what's the difference
between the two?
Just an H.
Hydrofluoric acid is a weak
acid, just a fluorine anion.
A negative fluorine
is a weak base.
And what's the difference
between the two?
They're just difference
of a hydrogen.
Let me write that down.
So let me write weak acid.
And then you have
your weak base.
So your weak base-- let me write
our weak acid is first.
We had hydrofluoric acid, and
then the weak base is when you
essentially just dump
the hydrogen, just
the hydrogen proton.
You kept the electron, so that's
why it's a negative
charge right there.
Hydrogen without its one
electron is just a proton
because it has no neutrons.
The other one was NH4 plus.
You dump one of the hydrogens
and you get NH3.
So what's the difference
going on?
These are all minus
a hydrogen.
Or if you go this way, you're
plus a hydrogen.
So you have these kind
of conjugates.
And this has all been a
long-winded way of introducing
you to this idea that you have
these conjugate pairs.
Like hydrofluoric acid, or
hydrogen fluoride and just the
fluorine anions.
So these are conjugate pairs.
Which are essentially two
molecules that are identical
except for a difference
in one hydrogen.
No more than one hydrogen.
One day there might be a test
where someone shows you two
molecules that are separated by
two hydrogens-- those would
not be conjugate pairs.
For example, if I show you H2O
and OH minus, these are
conjugate pairs.
Because this over here is
exactly this minus a proton.
And, in fact, let me be clear
that it's not just minus the
hydrogen-- minus the proton.
One of them is keeping
the electron.
So this is minus a hydrogen
proton, this is plus a
hydrogen proton.
So the difference between
these two are
just a hydrogen proton.
So these are conjugate pairs.
Now, if I were to say that H3O
and OH minus, you might be
tempted to say, hey, this is
very acidic, this is a base,
this is a conjugate pair.
But no, there's a 2 H,
2 proton difference.
This is H3O plus.
There's a 2 proton difference,
so these are
not conjugate pairs.
So let me just cross that out.
But these are.
Now, you could say, if you have
H3O, you might say, hey,
what's the conjugate base-- and
that's a new word I just
introduced you to-- what's the
conjugate base for H3O if H3O
is an acid?
Well, you take one H from
it and you get H2O.
So this is a conjugate pair.
And I just said a word without
defining it, so now
let me define it.
Within every conjugate pair you
have an acid and a base.
And if you say, oh, what is
the conjugate base for
hydrofluoric acid, you get rid
of a hydrogen and you say, oh,
it's just this fluorine anion.
If you said, I have some of
ammonia, as a base, what is
its conjugate acid?
So if someone asks you, what is
a conjugate acid, you add a
hydrogen proton to it and
you get ammonium.
So I could call these
the conjugate acid.
Let me just change terminology--
conjugate.
And we'll see that actually, you
don't have to be using a
weak acid or a weak base.
Conjugate acid, and then you
have a conjugate base.
And even though something might
be a conjugate acid or
conjugate base, it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're
very basic, for example,
or very acidic.
If I have hydrogen chloride, we
know this is a strong acid.
Hydrogen chloride.
Its conjugate base, we
essentially just get rid of
one of these hydrogen protons--
it doesn't take its
electron with it.
So it's just going to be the
chlorine negative ion.
This is its conjugate.
If I gave you a chlorine
negative ion and said, what's
its conjugate base-- what's its
conjugate acid? you'd say
it's hydrochloric acid.
If I gave you hydrochloric acid
and I say, what's its
conjugate base, you get rid of
a hydrogen proton only, and
you're left with the chlorine
negative ion-- You said that
its conjugate base.
Now, with that said, we know
that when you put hydrochloric
acid, we know this reaction.
This was I think the first
reaction we looked at in
aqueous solution.
It disassociates completely to
form hydrogen protons plus
chlorine anions-- everything,
of course,
in an aqueous solution.
Now, the fact that it
disassociates completely, that
this is not an equilibrium
reaction, this implies that
this guy is more basic
than water.
He has no temptation-- no, no--
let me say that he is
less basic than water.
He has no temptation to grab
these hydrogen protons from
the surrounding medium to reform
hydrochloric acid.
This reaction does not
go in this direction.
So even though this chlorine
anion, or negative ion of
chlorine, is a quote unquote
conjugate base of HCL, that
doesn't necessarily mean
it's that basic.
This is less basic than water.
It wants the hydrogen
protons less
than, let's say, hydronium.
So if you put some chlorine plus
some hydronium, or let's
say you have some H plus, you're
not going to reform
hydrochloric acid.
So this is not really basic even
though it's considered a
conjugate base.
And that's generally the case
whenever you're dealing with
strong acids, like in the case
of hydrochloric acid.
If I had a big solution of just
chlorine anions in water,
so I just had tons of a super
high concentration of chlorine
anions and water, because it's
not going to do anything to
change the actual hydrogen or
hydroxide concentration in the
water because it's less basic
than the water itself-- it
doesn't want to take or give
anything to the water-- the
PH, so if you have a soup,
the PH would be 7.
If you have chlorine minus in
an aqueous solution-- and I
don't care what its
concentration is, you could
have 10 molar of it-- the PH is
still going to be 7 because
it's not going to change
its solution.
It's not going to change the
PH, just this by itself.
Obviously, if you put
hydrochloric acid in an
aqueous solution this will
change it, because you're
going to be dumping all of these
hydrogen protons into
the solution.
So in general-- I mean, you can
kind of remember it, but I
think it's maybe common sense--
a strong acid's
conjugate base is neutral
in water.
Neutral.
So that means no impact on PH.
You say chlorine plus H2O, I
mean, you're essentially still
going to have chlorine
plus H2O.
You're not really changing
the concentration.
Now, on the other hand, when
you're dealing with weak
acids, so this reaction will
go in the other direction.
If you put some fluorine in
water, it will grab some
hydrogen-- not necessarily a
ton of it, but it will grab
some hydrogen from the
surrounding water-- and
increase the hydroxide
concentration.
It's increasing the
concentration of this thing
right here.
So it is making, in this
case, it is making the
solution more basic.
It's increasing the PH
of the solution.
So whenever you have a weak acid
its conjugate base will
be a weak base.
And you could make
this statement
the other way around.
If you have a conjugate-- let
me switch colors, this is
getting annoying-- conjugate
base-- sorry, a weak base, its
conjugate acid is going
to be a weak acid.
So hopefully you get
the idea here.
It's actually not that
fancy of an idea.
It's just that if you have an
acid, its conjugate base is
just that acid minus
a hydrogen.
If you have a base, its
conjugate acid is just that
thing plus a hydrogen.
Actually, let me just do a bunch
of problems here just to
really hit the point home of
what we're talking about.
Let's just do a bunch of them.
So if this is the acid and this
is its conjugate base, so
if I have-- I mean, you don't
even have to know the words.
If I have that, the conjugate
base, well, I'm just going to
get rid of a hydrogen proton.
So NO3 minus.
I didn't get rid of the whole
neutral hydrogen molecule.
Remember, I just took a proton
away, the electrons stay the
same, so I have a
negative charge.
Let's say we did H2SO4.
So its conjugate base, get
rid of a hydrogen.
HSO4 minus.
If I have hydrogen bromide,
get rid of a hydrogen.
It's BR minus.
And this is a strong acid.
So this is going to be a
neutral-- if you put this in
water, it's really not going to
do anything even though you
are calling it hydrogen
bromide's conjugate base.
Now, if we go the other way.
If we give you the base, if I
give you OH minus, what's its
conjugate acid?
Well, you add a proton
to it, you get H2O.
If I have H2O-- we already did
that-- you add a proton to it,
you get H3O plus.
If you have-- I mean, we
could just keep going.
Let's say I have that.
If I add a hydrogen
to it, I have H2.
There you go.
And it's neutral now because
I added a proton.
Anyway, hopefully I haven't
beaten this horse to death and
you understand what conjugate
acid and bases are all about.